mr lewis why did it take
matt hancock two days to be dragged
kicking and screaming from the
department in health
well i don't think that's a fair
description trevor i'm afraid i'm gonna
have to disagree with you
for the first part there look i think
quite rightly matt has been focused
all through this period the last year
and a half or more that we've been all
dealing with this
the dreadful situation with the pandemic
and focused on delivering for people
he wanted to stay focused on that the
government want to stay focused
we've got a strong team in the
department of health who have got that
knowledge that experience
to take that forward but look in his own
letter i think said
and ultimately he's he's right he's made
i think probably the right judgment in
the sense that he doesn't want
this situation around himself to
distract from that key focus and the key
work for government
which is to deliver for people on the
pandemic and as we are coming
out of the pandemic the secretary of
state
uh for health formally spent much of the
past year
telling the rest of us how to live our
private lives
he shamed people neil ferguson the
scientist for example
who broke the rules and yet he then
spent
two days telling everyone that it was
vital for him to stay in office
and that they shouldn't uh judge him on
the basis
of his private life he doesn't get it
does he
well as matt himself said he apologized
for what he had done he apologized for
breaching the the guidelines we've all
got to do our bit absolutely he's been
right all the way along we've all got to
do our bit to follow the guidelines
that helps keep not just ourselves and
our friends and our families but our
wider community is safer but
as matt said in his letter yesterday he
didn't want his own situation and
what he had done in terms of breaching
the guidelines in his private life
situation to distract from the important
work that we've all got to focus on i
know saji javi will be focused on
which is taking our country forward
through the next stage of the pandemic
and as we are rolling out of
the challenges of the pandemic as we
continue the vaccine rollout there's
been
a phenomenal success and something matt
and his team should be rightly proud of
yeah but this wasn't he forgot his mask
when he went into a shop
this was something quite different he
carried on a relationship fair enough
but in that relationship he did things
that he was telling
the rest of us that we may not do
and as matt said in his resignation
letter you know this is one of the
reasons why he took the decision
uh having given it some thought i think
he took the decision as he said that uh
it was right for him to not be a
continual distraction what he did was
wrong that's why he apologized
um and he wants the country to have the
ability to focus on dealing with the
pandemic and as i say these
next steps as we are coming out of the
pandemic i think it's a credit to matt
that his
first thought is around making sure the
country and the government can continue
to do the work we need to do as we are
moving out of the kovi pandemic
but mr lewis look let's get to
the root of this anybody can make a
mistake
but both mr hancock and mr johnson for
48 hours
carried on as though it was a minor slip
nothing uh was too wrong
and there is a sense this morning that
matt hancock
resigned not really because what he
thought what he had done was wrong was
but
but because everybody else is saying
it's
wrong and the prime minister doesn't
quite
in his letter say uh matt what you did
was
wrong and embarrassing in fact he uses
the word uh the phrase you should be
proud are matt hancock and boris johnson
the only people in the country who can't
see why he
re the real reason he had to go
well against trevor i'm afraid i
disagree with the premise that you're
coming from i think it's right the mat
and his entire team there's a really
good team of department health with um
nadine's heart we obviously lead this
phenomenal vaccine role out ed argher
james bethel the entire team there
nadine doyes and joe as well churchill
taking forward the work
to make sure the country is able to deal
with a pandemic and i think matt should
be proud of what he has seen at the hill
so it's not just dealing with a pandemic
which has been something
none of us um would have found an easy
project over the last year and a half
and he's done that with
clear focus and vigor to deliver for
people across the country and the
vaccine rollout but the technology
improvements in the nhs
the work to make gps more accessible and
to be ready
as we're coming out of the kobe pandemic
i do think it was right the prime
minister of matt were focused even in
the last couple of days
on making sure that experience that
knowledge that has been gained through
the last year and a half or so
of dealing with the pandemic was there
to be able to focus on the pandemic
i don't think that is in any
contradiction at all to matt after dale
so taking that opportunity to look at
the situation
and to reflect and decide that his
position was distracting from the work
as we come out of the pandemic and i
think
credit to matt that his focus is not
just on his family but on the wider
country in the best interest of the uk
let me try this another way
if something like this had taken place
in
your department the northern ireland
department
involving one of your junior ministers
and a person working for the department
i want you to tell me that it would take
you 48 hours
to decide that something had to be done
and that actually
you like the prime minister wouldn't say
to that
junior minister you've got to go
well the reason i never ever in any
interviews over the years i've been
talking to colleagues and yourself
trevor on a range of interviews i never
get into the hypotheticals is because
every situation
even in this situation trevor you've got
to look at the unique circumstances of a
situation like the pandemic
with the knowledge and the focus and the
experience that matt had had
leading the department through the
pandemic and the desire to keep the
focus on
how we use that expertise and that
knowledge to take the team forward and
the country forward as i said i think
matt
has made the right decision i think he's
done it with the best interests of
his family in the united kingdom at the
forefront
and credit to him for that because he
didn't want his situation to distract
from things you've got to look at these
situations
as they develop in real time with the
specific knowledge
of that particular situation so you
can't do hypotheticals across different
areas
our focus for the government i know
sanji javi's focus working with the
brilliant team at the department of
health
will be on moving forward the next steps
through and out of this pandemic
all right well let's leave matt hancock
himself alone for the moment and talk
about the government itself
because as you say the government's got
to take this forward now
to take it forward the government has to
retain its authority and know that
people are going to listen to it
now let me put this to you what it might
sound like to the person in the street
is cummings and barnard castle
hypocrisy matt hancock and some blokinos
gets ppe contracts cronyism
carrying the wallpaper in number 10
profligacy
and now snogging videos from the guy who
tells you you can't
hug your gran one rule for us and
one for them uh are you about to
squander
all of the credit that you have built up
as a government in the successful
vaccine rollout
oh well actually as i say i think the
vaccine model has been a phenomenal
success that's a credit to the deans of
harvey matt hancock himself
and the entire team at the health center
you've told me that five times
no we're going to be focused on
continuing to roll out the vaccines
we've got 83
of the public had that first dose now
over 60 percent had the second ocean
half of
under 30s as well which is brilliant but
we need to continue to focus on that and
i think ultimately what the public wants
us focused on
what my residency in great yarmouth and
people i talk to people in northern
ireland wants us focused on
is getting on with the job of government
making sure that we can continue to
deliver on that vaccine rollout
keep it going keep moving out of the
pandemic build back better and be ready
for the opportunities that lay ahead for
the united kingdom
mr lewis i i wouldn't normally do
something like this but um i want to
put a private personal question i guess
in a way to you
over the past two days every cabinet
minister including you
has come out to essentially defend
the prime minister and matt hancock
the pictures that we saw were of an
encounter on may the 6th
on may 11th my family buried my daughter
uh who had died not of kobe but during
the lockdown
300 of our family and friends turned up
online
but most of them were not allowed to be
at the graveside
even though it was in the open air
because of the rule of
thirty because of the instruction
by mr hancock now the next time one of
you
tells me what to do in my
private life explain to me why i
shouldn't
just tell you where to get off
well i i absolutely accept and
understand the frustration even the
anger that people have having been
through
the situations they've been through look
as you say to other people across the
country i've lost friends as funerals
i've not been able to go to
over the last period that is such a
tragic situation for any of us to be in
and that's
i have to say why it's so important all
of us do what we can to
keep ourselves our families our friends
our wider community
safe it's also why that what matt did
was wrong he
acknowledged that's why he apologized
immediately for his baby and acknowledge
what he did was wrong
and it's ultimately why he's taken the
decision that his position was untenable
and distracting from the wider work that
we've all got to do
to move forward in the pandemic and out
of the pandemic there's no getting away
from that and i think that's why matt
ultimately made the decision he did as i
say i think in doing that
he has put his family and indeed all of
us across the uk first because he wants
to focus
as the pm does as we all do to be on
getting out of this pandemic
in the best possible way and as quickly
as we can okay i'm going to have
one last attempt does any of you
understand
the fact that it took two days to get it
to this point
feels to everybody who is not you
like he only only stepped down
because everybody else was shouting at
him
not because he or the prime minister
actually understood what this
feels like to everybody else
well as i said trevor earlier on i'm
afraid i don't disagree with the premise
you set out i think the prime minister
of matt and i think people will
see that the prime minister matt hancock
were focused on dealing with the
pandemic that's what they saw as the
prime thing matt accepted what he did
was wrong and apologize for that
and i think credit to matt that he's
looked at it again on reflection and
taking the view that his position
was distracting from that wider piece
work he wants like we all want
our focus to be on dealing with the
pandemic and the next stages as we come
out of that
and that's certainly where all of the
government's focus will be and sergi
javid
and the team of the health department
will be looking forward to how we
develop
out of the pandemic from a health sense
as all of us will more widely
as a country as we build back better in
the future
all right we'll come to mr jarvis
challenges in a moment but um
before we do that i want to ask you
about the security aspects of this you
are well versed in this area though of
course this specific
issue will not be your responsibility um
we don't know exactly how anybody
came to be in possession of these
pictures
but presumably the government will be
undertaking an urgent
security review because
how is it possible that what goes on in
a minister's office or behind
a closed door for a minister can be
made public in this way i mean for matt
hancock it was embarrassing
i think in your case it could be lethal
all right well look trevor you're quite
right and i've seen some of the reports
this morning outlining how
different uh journalists think that the
tape may have got out there that is sony
mata i know the
department of health will be looking
into to understand
exactly how that was recorded and how it
got out of the system it's something we
need to get to the bottom of as you say
quite rightly what happens in government
departments can be sensitive and
important
and it's but people need to have the
confidence that what is happening
in a government department is something
that allows government to be focused on
those core issues
and the sensitivity sometimes in a
security sense of those core issues so
yes i do know that is something the
department of health
will be taking forward as an internal
investigation we need to see let them
have the space to do that
to understand how this happening to
ensure this kind of situation
um can't happen again or across
government indeed it doesn't look good
though does it because um literally just
before i came on there i don't know if
you're aware of this
news broke that uh sensitive documents
uh about the uh defense
establishment and movements of our
warships were discovered at a
bus stop in kent by a member of the
public
yes no i'm i'm aware of this uh as well
trevor
as i say the as you rightly say it's
something that none of us want to see
shouldn't be able to happen
uh it was properly reported at the time
into the ministry of defense there was
obviously an internal investigation
intact situation as well
and we've got again i've got to wait and
allow the team at the department of
defense to
ministry of defense to work through that
investigation to understand exactly how
this
managed to occur um mr javed
uh i gather we'll be speaking to the
press
later on this morning he's got a big
entry um
completing vaccine rollout uh catching
up with the backlog
maybe five million uh patients
unwinding the reforms from a decade ago
not to mention uh social care the
americans have this expression a
hospital pass
which is when you throw the football to
somebody who's about to be
uh buried under three 200
ton um opposition defenders um
is mr javed getting a hospital pass with
uh the department of health and social
care now
not a tool i know the analogy my
football days may be a bit behind me and
i was probably one of those
larger defenders you refer to trump but
we're very fortunate in our parties have
such a great depth of talent and having
sadji javi with
such a phenomenal wide experience across
government leading key big departments
coming back in means we've got somebody
who knows how to get things done who
knows how to
manage and run a department and he is
going to be working with what is a
phenomenal team in the department of
health really strong ministers
a team that's worked so well together
through the pandemic to deliver for
people across the country in the most
challenging times that our health
service has ever seen and i know that
saggy will be
absolutely laser focused on making sure
that we're able to move forward in a
positive way
i suppose the prime minister reminded
him that he's not just secretary of
state for health
but also for social care um we
understood that there was going to be
the beginnings at least of a proposal
uh for social care emerging this week
will mr jarvid still tell us what the
government wants to do
on social care or is that going to be
delayed yet again
oh well the prime minister has outlined
that we'll be coming forward with some
plans before the end of the year that
will be the focus of the department
health as i say the whole team helen
waitley and
ed garga the whole team working with uh
sanji javid who
as i say will be somebody who is focused
on getting things done
and delivering this is a hugely we all
know it's a very very not just sensitive
but a really
complicated area i used to be a local
myself there's obviously a huge
work across sajid has got great
experience of that from his time at
communities and local government and
understanding how that comes together
and delivering something that can really
work for people
in a way that's fair and gets the job
done so people have got that confidence
in older age to be able to look forward
so that is something we want to do by
the end of the year and i know sanji
will be focused on that as much as he is
on that wide range of issues as we are
developing out of the kovi pandemic